[Music]
hi lisa hi vivek
hi stephen hi lisa i'm really excited to
talk to you both today about this
lisa tell me a bit about the hair has no
gender project
well this is really part of pantene's
journey to
bring everyone more great hair days and
hair has no gender is really about
telling
and amplifying the stories and the
voices of our transgender
and gender non-binary communities to
really show the power
that hair has in expressing um you know
personal identity and self-expression
and really then calling on all canadians
to be vocal
allies we believe that gender is not
distinguished by hair
and that hair is not defined by gender
your hair is fantastic vivid
i love it tell me what role would you
say
your hair plays in your own
self-expression
yeah so i mean when pantene approached
me i was super excited because i feel
like hair is such a big part of who i am
as an
individual i think starting as a child
i learned that hair was kind of an
inexpensive way
to express your individuality and your
identity and i think as
my identities have evolved so has my
hair you know i've been growing this out
i was counting today i think seven years
and i feel like i'm a different person
now than i was seven years ago so
i think that hair is such an important
part
of our community's stories and the way
that we express ourselves
i love the idea of recreating family
photos with the ambassadors this film
series is
when i was watching it it was emotional
for me it was thought provoking
it was educational vivek how did it feel
to go
back with your dad and recreate a photo
like this because this is something
you're going to look back
on and be able to smile at in many years
to come
i feel like i have this like keepsake
that i can always look back on and be
like wow we
found a way to not only you know
recreate this photo but also
reconnect in a way that i feel like
we're still trying to do
um in our older ages obviously i was
moved sitting next to my dad but i also
felt kind of nervous because my dad and
i you know our relationship
is kind of broad and so this is a very
new thing for us to do together to sit
together and talk about
feelings and history but watching the
film back i was like oh wow like
look at the way he looks at me like i
was just i couldn't take my eyes
off of like the love in his eyes which
again i felt like
kind of deepened the message that i was
trying to hit in the film
that acceptance does have a range of
acceptance looks like a range of ways
and you know i think it for me watching
the film it's a reminder to actually
look in the eyes of the people who love
you because again sometimes they're not
saying it with words but they're saying
it with their eyes so yeah i was very
very very moved
i've had to really broaden my idea
of what acceptance looks like was it
christmas or diwali
no it's christmas listen you said in the
video
that you had to broaden your idea of
acceptance
and i think that's a very powerful
statement so tell me
what has that journey been like for you
i think as
you know a queer person as a trans
person when i turn on the tv and i see
stories of acceptance you always have
like
you know the mom at the pride ceremony
or you know
the the stubborn dad who at the end of
the show
will be like i love you son and you know
i never got those kinds of forms of
acceptance i think what's beautiful
about you know hair has no gender is
that it shows that
you know a acceptance is important and
crucial and that we need acceptance from
allies to be able to express ourselves
and have the confidence to express
ourselves
but also that acceptance can have many
forms so
i think you know spreading the word
about the films is a really great
starting point
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos